hello everybody welcome to Android
design in action our sixth show sixth is
actually one of the hardest words
meaningful anguish to pronounce which I
just found out but Android design in
action is a show where we look at
different elements of Android design we
usually take a look at specific
applications and how their user
interfaces can be improved using you
know the elements of Android design
which are very well documented on the
Android design site but today we're
going to be looking at rich
notifications and local video players as
you can see clearance lights but before
we get started we should probably
introduce ourselves as always uh my name
is Roman Nurik hi guys Adam crush and a
quick check here in London yes I should
mention that Adam and I are broadcasting
live to you from New York all right so
let's get started with Android design in
action local video and rich notification
um what we did today was we didn't look
at any specific local video players you
know that were previously reviewed on
the App clinic I believe they're
actually doing that because of some sort
of technical difficulties but what we
what we did today was instead of looking
at specific apps we came up with an
example app that you know did some of
the simple some similar things but it
wasn't branded in any way it's not kind
of like a published app and we have no
intentions of publishing it it's really
just kind of a what if you know what if
we were to design a local video player
from scratch and we didn't do all the
screens and we only did just a few of
the screens primarily around the Browse
experience we won't be talking too much
about video playback because you know
while you're playing the video you know
there's a lot of things that you can
really do and we have some examples of
apps that do it really well for example
the YouTube app does a fairly good job
with that so if you're already starting
to create a local video player or a
video player in general you should
probably model your playback screen
after something like YouTube um but what
we did do is look at browse screens and
things like that before we get started
anybody else have any things to add to
the exposition for the show
just say a bit of the show that
unfortunately don't have a fancy studio
set up this week so while the stream
quality might be a little bit lower you
can and get the slides downloads later
so if you're watching this look at the
description in the YouTube video and it
should be a link to get high quality
slides if you can't quite make out all
the visuals and then click through to
that link yeah and we're gonna post the
slides and I think like 2560 x 1440 you
something resolution so you get all the
little super HD something super super
super HD 4d four dimensions okay anyway
so let's jump into the to the screens so
this is our example local video player
and well I probably could have taken up
more space on the screen and just I
think you're fun but this is our example
video yeah yeah this is an example a
video player that just again local
content and it shows you you know a
couple of things and basically this is
the rough structure of this app is that
you know you could imagine that you
categorize your local videos into
different groups or categories will show
there in a second and then you know you
might have a queue of like you know
local videos that you plan on watching
and then you probably want to have you
know some sort of sense of what has been
recently added what I've you know
recently looked at or whatever recently
added to my device so this screen is
kind of your up next screen which is
kind of like a dashboard or home screen
and we chose here to to showcase the the
two probably most important things in my
family's um you know for local video
playback and for in general media
consumption is what's up next right
either stuff that I've recently added or
stuff that have explicitly added to a
queue now you'll notice that there are a
couple things you can do with this Q you
can first uh actually all my mouse is
moving that's good um you can first
reorder the Q items by using the this
kind of dragging affordance to the left
of each list item and this is something
that is you could find in the Google
Play Music app within a playlist to
reorder tracks and then below the
q there's there's kind of the recently
added list and it's more it's not really
a list as as it is more like a set of
tiles I mean you've seen this several
times in the show we use this this
presentation of content fairly
frequently because you know it's very
versatile it works across you know
different device sizes it works across
different aspect ratios of content it's
in general very very versatile what I
wanted to point out here is that you
know there's a lot that you can do with
this tile area and it's going to be
really hard to show here let's see if
this works so zooming in on my laptop is
not work unfortunately but there's a lot
of detail in these tiles if you look at
the the top right thailand recently
added you'll notice that there's a
little status indicator indicating that
something is in the queue so this is
something that you know again you could
use this for starring or bookmarking or
in this case queuing it's a good nice
little non-interactive indicator that
this is a special item and in this case
it really means this is already in your
queue this is just like you would see in
like in the gmail or such of something
you start it has an indicator indicates
the other thing is that you can swipe to
dismiss items from the queue so we're
not really using a horizontal swipe for
anything else on the screen any of you
were you know we'd be able to still use
bezel swipe to access adjacent lateral
content but in this case a queue is
something that naturally lends itself to
swipe to dismiss so you can dismiss
items you know get rid of them off of
your queue by just swiping them away
before we move on to other screens any
any clouds guys personally I think it
said it's a very nice treatment I think
a problem with look at these video
playing apps as they seem to cut
straight a lot on the video playback
which is also mean it's the core utility
but then this they kind of don't make a
huge amount of effort to follow any
design guidelines for the for the kind
of file management type tasks and it
seems like a you know it's a lot of apps
like in the early 90s when everyone was
building win up skins it's all about the
visual
like having you know seventeen thousand
different format play bags but then no
efforts being spent on the thing that
kind of actually gets you into that
prisoner so I really like the treatment
here especially I like the queue
management features with this white to
dismiss I think that really works very
well head and I guess I kind of like how
q is given the priority here and it's a
sort of infinitely growing list so there
can be a ton of items in your queue and
then below that you've got recently
added which may not be as important but
kind of nice to browse and you could
possibly add those items straight to you
which you can think of that my eyes on
indicating to reverse looking like this
is actually very similar to the People
app to like you know in the People app
you have you know your favorites tab and
your favorites tab you have top items
which are your starred people or your
favorite people kind of a cure quick
dial and below that you know in case you
haven't favorite anybody or even if you
have you know it's kind of extra content
it's kind of below the fold it's not as
important as your favorites but you know
your recent or frequently called or
frequently contacted people are also
something that you probably want to have
access to yeah and then if your Q is
like is a is getting kind of short
there's not that many items in it then
you instantly can see there's recently
added items and sleep you're mad
simulated yeah exactly alright so let's
move on to just something you can even
looked up how do you envisage the app
the action of adding something to the
key from here so I mean adding something
to the queue is a good question and like
we haven't really again we haven't gone
into video playback or video detail
screens but I visited that it will that
even more in this yeah i imagine that
like you know when you long press any
video from anywhere right you enter a
contextual i guess the contextual
selection mode and then you can long
press multiple videos and then in the
contextual action bar you have kind of
NQ or add to queue you and then on the
video playback screen by default you
probably wouldn't show the action bar if
I'd be hidden because you want you and
have the full screen viewing experience
when you touch the screen once your
status bar your action bar and your
video controls pop up and in the action
bar you have like add to queue just in
case you wanna or maybe it's called like
watch later or something just in case
you don't want to like
you know watch right now right there to
figure if one is quite a she I think
yeah the contextual action bar before II
would have what am I my favorite kind of
Android design paradigms because he can
it lends itself really well to handling
not only single selection of multi
selection in quite a elegant way which
are very much like so if you long press
on one video from this critically
example you you can see the action bar
would transform into options suitable
for a single video so there might be
different set of options supported
multiples but then as he touched to
select more items within the grid the
action bar can then refine its selection
to just those actions suitable for
multiple which is I think a very elegant
design and handle this learning and the
other thing is just you know users in
general are very a cut or Android users
are very accustomed to using long press
to trigger context menus and in our case
I mean I guess since android through
point O I guessing before for now you
know we've been using long press as
really selection and context like you
know entering a selection context and
providing extra actions is really kind
of a secondary thing right so first
select the things you want to act on and
then see the different options available
to you rather than you know long press
and immediately have options or actions
available only on this view you interact
with something from the same examples of
that kind of behavior if you want to
further look into that in gallery just
is quite nice quite nicely and gmail
also does it is a good show of this
could have multi selection behavior yeah
and then we have a bunch of open source
code in the iOS iOS read project the
google io 2012 app that does multiple
selection and single selection sexual
action bar alright so let's move on to
the next screen this is so let's say you
touch that that spinner what do you see
and like i said earlier like i mentioned
earlier you have different categories so
you know you're up next or your cute
items would be you know a dynamic
category that would be updated
constantly and then you could categorize
videos into you know custom categories
like let's say family videos or ted
talks since ted provides i think most of
their videos in an open format and then
maybe cartoon clips you know stuff that
you're working on things like that and
then this would be custom
sizable by you right so maybe this is
depending on what app you're building
this could be folders this could just be
like tags or what it collections
whatever it is it's really up to you
there's just an example so using a
spinner so then once you select one of
the items let's say family videos you
get presented with a I guess detail or
the category detail screen which gives
you a list of items in that category
that are organized by some you know some
attribute so in this case state and then
when you touch on the sort or the filter
or whatever you want to call it action
button you get presented with different
ways to categorize your content so this
immediately lets you you know apply
filtering apply a better more easily
consumable perspective on your videos
rather than seeing you know extremely
long stream of all the different videos
you have even in a certain category you
can immediately filter by a different
you know things like Idol year or
percent view actually present view to
something I want to call out you can't
really see it here but in that tile
imagine you know that I've seen already
forty percent of the video let's say
it's like a to our wedding video right
and I'm forty percent of the way in um
so let's say I'm like forty percent of
the way in right um I think one of the
most important things to bubble up is
that hey you've already seen forty
percent of this and to finish off
watching this video there's only like
ten minutes left so instead of showing
the full duration of the video in the
file in this case we've chosen and again
you're not going to make this hat here
but there's a little like eyeball icon
and it says seventy two percent there's
about 31 minutes left or something so so
this is just one example of one of the
things you can tweak within a tile since
you have lots of screen real estate and
like I said before I mean you have this
the sorting option and from there you
can choose you know to filter by title
so the section headers good abcdefg and
so on um year or or duration thanks to
that alright and then the last thing on
the screen is the tablet version since
we all
to show at least one tablet screen shot
for the different things we look at so
in this case we've taken a look at that
initial up next screen we've imagined
what it could look like on a 7-inch
tablet in this case of Nexus 7 in
landscape so what you basically have is
instead of a stacked single lid you have
two separate columns and the left you
have the Q and the right you have
recently viewed and you'll notice that
each each of those list items has just
more space so for the qu we've broken it
out into kind of a larger item larger
thumbnails same size text but a
different treatment of text and then for
the for the actual tiles those again
should should probably scale to take up
exactly fifty percent of their list in
width and then maintain the aspect ratio
right so with that extra space you can
show more of the text potentially you
know anything else you want to show
about the video like again time viewed
or if people are tagged in it you can
show that things like that and so that
was the last screen shot before we move
on to rich notifications any parting
words at it for I guess local video in
general i donate you know I like to
treatment this screen i think this sir
it's very nice and balanced the way you
think the things you feel put picked out
there about how the changes you've made
from the smaller list view to the large
but side by side of you it's really
calls out how you want to treat like
having thoughts about ahead of time how
you're going to treat the different
amounts of space rather than just
stretching everything and keeping the
same aspect ratios but really kind of
optimizing to take advice to that extra
space i had one comment you just get
back once morning is yep um I kind of
like about this is a kiss depending on
the type of videos that you're looking
at the sort of ordering or sorting would
be important so for example family
videos you know by a certain by date or
by a year in this case is fairly
important one nice thing to add here and
it might be there already imagining that
sort of section indexer or who good
later sort of scroll up at their I'm
going so if you have you know a ton of
different videos maybe baby videos or
wedding video
or else you could quickly skip up and
down and look at all of this from videos
yeah and then if you have maybe TED
talks and you sort of trying to look at
something by title you could switch the
title and do the same thing so sort of
it's a lot of power here being up can
navigate through a pretty broad array of
different video types yeah and I think
for Ted videos like one of the things
that I would probably filter on is you
know duration or percent viewed so like
you know I have I'm gonna go on the
train right now I have 10 minutes right
what can i watch from Ted that's 10
minutes long like this is something that
that's really important to me in general
is time so like not only for local video
but reading right for articles you
should always show the rough amount of
time that this will take you to read
because i know that i'm on the train i
have five minutes rhyme on i'm walking
to the train i probably shouldn't you
reading my phone but you know i have and
you know exactly this amount of time
what can i do in that time and i think
that you know giving you the option to
filter by size or length or duration or
you know i guess in the case of percent
viewed how much you have left like three
minutes left in this video and that's a
fairly powerful way of organizing the
last thing I point out is that you
probably make it sticky right so for
family videos you'd always you know do
year for ted talks you would I guess not
always but show the last soaring you
apply for that category yeah alright so
in the interest of time since we have 10
minutes left let's go jump into rich
notifications so Nick you want to you
know talk about rich notification yeah i
just said also a little note on this
segment as well so we're trying to
introduce some more content into design
in action so as well as just doing
straight up at redesigns we're going to
try and highlight some of the cool
awesome features that make android
android really so this is why we've
picked rich notifications today to do it
a deep dive until one of what i think
one of the more exciting features in the
joy being launched so androids always
had a very strong a notification story i
think it's been one of my favorite
features that it kind of true sickly
lets you know what's going on without
you having to dive in and out of
applications all the time will have true
civ kind of modal dialogues pop up so
it's been one of my favorite features
for a long time and what happened in the
JV release is they kind of got
supercharged they've got out of some
lots of additional functionality
so we're going to take you to your few
examples of what you can do and how you
might go about designing for this
feature so straight up here as you can
see this is a fairly standard looking
and notification which we would call
kind of like a one unit of size
notification or one you might refer to
it here showing the standard information
so you have a headline and a subtext
straight line and what you can do is by
running the finger down the notification
you can then expand it out to a greater
size so this is example we've taken here
and for a video playback an online video
streaming service which is say you've
just kind of paused or abandoned
playback from another device or another
computer or laptop or whatever and we
were taking that opportunity to then
present the user with an opportunity to
resume exactly where they left off so I
think this is hugely compelling having
this additional kind of still frame
calling out the last moment you put up
too much more compelling than just some
piece of text telling you that you can
resume which I really like and right
there there's an action in the
notification as well so as well as
providing information it provides a
strong call-to-action to then go and do
this and the reason we pick this this
video kind of resumption kind of idea
was to highlight another feature of the
new notifications API is the ability to
have what we're calling an opportunistic
notifications that is by default which
your standard form of notification will
add an icon into the use of status bar
so they can see hey there's a message
waiting something's happened requiring
your attention as of the latest release
and you can now provide a priority to
the notification one of which is you can
say this is a minimum priority
notification in which case the system
will not notify the user with an icon
but it's kind of like opportunistic in
the sense that if the users in the
notification tray then will display to
them anyway don't ever example of this
might be Google now for example which
can let you know the weather and what's
going to be like the next couple of
hours and but it says hey this isn't
super important information I'm going to
interrupt the user and tell them about
it but should they be in the
notification trace even what's going on
then I'm going to present this
information to them so we've kind of
used the power of this opportunity and
education combined with you know showing
a large image anak strong call to action
to kind of add a really cool little
feature to a pedestrian service there
all right now I love this for you know a
Netflix or Hulu or something I love that
like ability to just remind you know
just open up the notification shade and
so you know actually I do have you know
a few minutes right now to watch you
know the rest of this futurama episode
or something um let me just touch that
and jump into it you know one thing I
just want to focus on so we're talking
about this is that some people might
wonder like how is this crossing the
territory of like what my going to a
widget it's compared to the notification
I'd say the key being that time
sensitive to you really like I'd say
this is the kind of thing you might want
to pop up I just say for 15-20 minutes
shows notification if the user hasn't
you know jumped into it at that point
then i would probably remove it because
an education should be about timely
information and whereas a widget can be
more about like just the latest things
that have happened more of a digest at
remove on let's all right next one so we
hopped back to one of our previously
visited applications in design in action
and we've had a look at a London
Underground application which gives you
information about what's going on on the
tube one of the important things to me
as a Londoner can be if a if there's a
service interruption I'm going to have
to replan my journey somehow so that's
important that they showed me an
education but rather than having to make
me go into the application and kind of
do something what we've done here is if
we swipe down on the notification we've
used the big text style which allows you
to provide additional textual
information and in addition to so once
expanded it so here is an example of big
text lets you kind of let the user know
what's going on and I can process it I
can just swipe it away and get rid of it
but I don't think the message can affect
me work and then click rooting into the
application so yeah this is example the
big textile another option in like let's
say you have the ability to do you know
rerouting or something and let's say
this app knows about your trips or your
destination you could offer actions here
like you know find an alternate route or
or
look at the you know full details of in
this case you know touching it should
probably give you the details on the on
the error or something and then maybe
the in actions like look at alternate
routes and besides in this case the
circle liner cool lots of different okay
next next notification thing so yeah
those are two of the built-in style to
come with a platform which you can just
say hey I want if you show a big image
or any show a larger amount of text that
a normal notification might but with the
update notifications you can also get
and like a blank canvas and draw
whatever is your application wants to do
so we've revisited the tripadvisor app
which we took a look at a couple of
weeks back and visit what they could do
so here scenario when visiting is
someone's just arrived in it in a new
city and they've detected this location
change and we're kind of like
preemptively offering them and see what
what's going on attractions around them
so straight away the minimized version
you just say kind of all welcome to
London it says see nearby attractions
but if we were to swipe down we can
actually provide a completely custom I
can lay out within the notification
itself so here it would explain to kind
of tiles like picking out the top two
new attractions middle use or what
they've just arrived in a new city which
might be kind of fun but yeah really
this is just a window into your
application so you can completely extend
your brand dating your look and feel
right into the next occasion bar yeah
and then one thing you can offer here
again as further actions maybe you know
see all or you know search for a
specific area like if for some reason
the app accidentally like just didn't
get your location right you could say
you know choose a different location or
something like that so providing actions
I mean almost always there are multiple
things you can do on notifications and
providing extra actions or just like
it's just a really really easy easy way
to provide extra functionality without
much effort it's one of my favorite
functions on Android so it means it
leads to less jumping around with clean
applications I no longer have to kind of
go in and out in and out and have these
in the context which is all the time I
find with the introduction of Richard
education so I find myself processing
information and staying on top of things
and doing quick actions straight from
the notification I find it really
satisfying make you feel super
tippin powerful so I really encourage
all designers and developers to think
about how you can use this this newly
expanded functionality in your apps well
one quick thing I wanted to mention on
the sort of technical implementation
side is that the support library has a
particle notification compat that sort
of allows you to build these rich
notifications but also basically degree
to earlier versions of Android so it's
definitely recommended to use that so
that you can start using these
immediately and not worry about um you
know maybe think any compatibility for
other versions of Android yeah basically
you know lets you not do like if build
that SD kit version that version codes
or whatever it lets you avoid all that
it just does that for you so you know
worry about it's totally totally make
excuses you gotta start using them now
you saying exactly cool okay we weren't
in time so let's do a quick fly through
and which is unusual your room all right
Android design news then we need like a
drum roll or like a gun thank you yeah
we have Daniel Pham from from Memphis
and he's a he's providing our drum rolls
for this evening okay this morning so
first very quickly so Taylor Ling hua I
guess a common name that we talked about
on design or in our design new segment
totaling has come back and a done a a
password manager redesigned so this is
kind of like a reimagining of a password
manager basically something that manages
your passwords that kind of uses
different techniques like the Google now
style cards and crouton which we'll talk
about in a second croutons for for kind
of a messages that pop up from the top
and it just overall in my opinion it's
kind of a solid starting point for for
kind of like a hollow style patrick been
moving on holo there Nick you want to
talk about hollow there yeah it's a
tumblr that's been out there for a
little while but we swear this call it
outside doing and similar to this show
they're taking applications and
reimagining them in a hollywood-style so
if you looking for some inspiration for
how you might implement some hollow look
and feel then it's a great great source
for that so if this is your blog then
then get in touch on google+ or don't
let us know because we didn't actually
know who to attribute this to but and
put the good work all right Murray
strikes again next since you know you
just spent some time with Murray in
Berlin you want to talk about her recent
work yeah absolutely so and I've just
got back from Berlin of the weekend
where there was a dead test going on so
it was great to kind of hang out the
Android developers and hackers over in
Berlin one of whom was Murray who is
frustrated with bloggers interface and
thinks that it needs a little bit of a
refresher she's taken the kind of
slightly tired I brother look and feel
and given a fresh hollow coat of paint
so I think she's done a really nice job
here of marrying the branding of
bloggers the question Brandon with with
hope and not content with just that one
one redesigned she actually is also that
are quite quite in depth redesign of the
sixth car rental application as well
which i think is much much better than
the official apps I already hope that 62
paying attention can take a look at that
hiring muriate it and make this happen
alright moving on showcase view so this
is something that that's come up a
couple of times in the app clinic even
so let's say there is something in this
case I think it's kind of may not be
used in the best possible way but let's
say there's something that's kind of
like a very difficult to discover
feature and it's it's not necessarily
like well labeled like with some sort of
gesture or something I'm show Keys view
is a little tool that'll give you this
kind of blue overlay that you can use as
a one-time kind of help help dialogue or
help what everyone called help overlay
so when you when you use your first
opens the app if there's something
that's kind of very difficult to
discover then you may want to you know
show this before you jump in and start
using it you should read our design
pattern on help which talks about the
specific cases where you should use
something like this in general you
should try avoiding on screen tutorials
or things because you know your
interface you just explain itself and if
there's a problem with labeling then do
better labeling
but if you do find an area where like
it's a gesture or something that's like
super super super important then you
know you may want to use your facebook
and crouton once about detox yannick
rajanna so Cuchulain is a initially it
came from a blog post below mr. Cyril ma
ta who had some frustrations with the
Android toast class which is a way of
kind of like giving these transitive
kind of messages that kind of show up
for a while disappear but some of the
limitations of it were annoying him in
that it wasn't really kind of attached
to an activity so if you were to show a
toast message and then switch away to
another activity message may remain be
out of context so he has come up with a
toast like API for showing more
contextual messages so you can have info
messages and error message in song like
within the flow of the application so he
kind of out like this and a blog post
button but she couldn't release any co2
think it was an the IPO is owned by his
employer so mr. Benjamin vice another
Berlin hacker has has taken this idea
and run with it and open source the
crouton library oh you she can find on
github and so it's under active
development and getting words over
contributions and stars and I encourage
you take a look at it ends it might
provide you a nice way to give these
contextual in our messages all right and
is that it or not we had one more from
cyril strikes again so this is this is a
Polaris it's released a library called
Polaris which is a book on top of Google
Maps add-on and it basically gives you
things like you know standardize on
screen my location buttons sanitize on
screen zoom buttons also standardized on
scream on screen rather info bubbles so
bowls or bookings or whatever you want
to call them their pop up above markers
when you touch on so yes I really like
this for a couple reasons not only able
to make it make your developers life
easier to implement mapping features but
for me it also released analyzes the
interactions likes to be a very similar
to map so maps is probably one of the
most used apps and androids and if
you've got a deviate from the kind of
patterns like where they can locate me
button is or how balloons pop up and so
on their new apps going to just feel
kind of slightly off and I think
this pilars library will really help in
getting that kind of consistent feel all
right I think that's the last one yes
that was the last item so um that was
Android design and in action for this
week / 16 for whatever so I think that's
all the time we have and we're about
three minutes over so sorry about that
you're running to your meeting and like
you have your laptop or something you
catch the end of the show sorry about
that you can now sign off as always
thanks again my name is Roman Nurik so
you guys edible cosh x from the ninja
flip chip and catch you guys next week
peace out